last week I told you that we would be
finalizing the coffee labels for the
upcoming david pakman show coffee blends
you have voted overwhelmingly for
Madeleine quirks designs I really
thought that this was going to be closed
because there were so many good
submissions but by a longshot Natalie
quirks designs were selected let's take
a look at a couple of these designs were
still finalizing colors this is one of
the one of the color combinations for
freedom of the press which is going to
be the drip coffee blend we also have
one other color get know we have
progressive wake-up call this is one of
the designs for the espresso blend which
is called progressive wake-up call those
the same color patterns there same color
patterns and then here's another set of
color patterns for these this is the
freedom of the press design with some
different colors and then we also have
the Madeleine quirks progressive wake up
call design in other patterns so we will
be finalizing these and very soon the
coffee's going to be available you're a
big coffee guy right Pat yeah I've been
trying to drink a little bit less
because I think I've been going a little
overboard with the caffeine really I'd
say I average about two cups a day when
if you are you at the point where if you
don't drink coffee an entire day you get
a headache not now I'm not that bad but
it's just kind of my morning routine I
don't second guess it yeah no that's
good yeah I I avoid drinking so much
coffee that when I don't drink it
there's any kind of side effects or
anything like that which for me is
basically I have a cappuccino in the
morning and that's typically and if I
have coffee in the afternoon I'll have
decaf but needless to say regardless of
whatever Pat's coffee habits are it's
good to know that we're finalizing the
designs and the coffee will be available
soon discuss this in any other stories
from the show on the david pakman show
read it at david pakman.com slash re d
di t